Hey everybody, welcome to the podcast.
I am very excited because today's guest,
perhaps more than any other person beyond my wife has had,
without knowing it an unbelievably profound impact
on my life, on my career and how I think about
and pursue self-expression.
His name is Steven Pressfield.
He's a novelist, he's a screenwriter,
and the guy behind some
of the most important nonfiction books
on creativity that I have ever read,
including of course, "The War of Art,"
which you've likely heard me talk
about quite frequently on the podcast
because it impacted me so deeply.
It's a book all about how to bring voice to
and manifest your best, most creative self.
So, we're gonna talk about that today.
We're gonna talk about creativity more generally.
We're gonna talk about Steven's brand new book,
"A Man at Arms," which is fantastic.
Everybody check that out.
I hold this man and his work in the absolute highest regard.
I can't thank him enough for the gift of his work.
It truly did change my life
and I'm super honored to have him on the show
to share his wisdom with all of you guys today.
So, hit that Subscribe button and please,
only takes a second.
Let's do the thing.
This is me and Steven Pressfield.
Steven, I can't tell you how happy I am to meet you
and to have you here.
It's such a privilege and such an honor.
Before we get into it there's
a little bit of construction next door.
They told us they were gonna knock it off
but we'll see how that goes.
So, for people that are listening or watching
if you hear some sawing in the background,
not much we can do about it.
We're just gonna have to live with it.
But in any event, this is a long time coming and-
Let me say the same thing to you, Rich,
while we're at it,
that I've been really lookin' forward
to this for a long time.
I've admired your stuff, your books, this work you do.
And we only live a few miles apart.
I just drove over the hill.
I know, I know.
So, this is a real thrill for me.
I'm a little nervous and I'm lookin'
forward to it.
I'm nervous, too.
First of all, thank you.
I can't tell you how flattering that is to hear
from somebody like yourself
because of all people in my life,
like I don't know of anyone
who's had a more profound impact on my life and on my career
and how I think about what it is that I do then yourself.
At least of people that I've never met before.
Like, your work has been so tremendously influential
and impactful on me personally.
And I just wanna thank you for that
because I really believe that I would not have done any
of the things that I've done
in my life had I not come across
your amazing work.
Wow, really?
Yeah.
Great.
And that's just a fact.
That's not, I'm not embellishing.
That's not an exaggeration in any regard.
I vividly remember, I got out of rehab in 1998
and was really grappling with who I wanted to be
and who I was and the decisions that I had made
and "The Artist's Way" was introduced to me
and I started working that program
and that was my first introduction to trying
to connect with something deeper inside of myself
and the process of doing the morning pages really
unlocked something in me.
I wasn't sure what that was yet, but I knew I had
this instinct that I had a creative spark inside of me
that there was something there to be mined
and to be paid attention to.
But I was looking for how to kind of amplify
that a little bit more or dig a little bit more deeply
into what that might be when
I was introduced to "The War of Art."
And it was through my friend, Sacha Gervasi,
who's a screenwriter who's been
on this podcast a couple times.
Have you ever met Sacha?
No, no.
He's the biggest evangelist of your work.
And when he was-
And were you workin'
as an entertainment lawyer
at that time?
I was a lawyer at the time.
Yeah, and Sacha's one of my better friends
and he was a big proponent
of morning pages and "The Artist's Way."
And he's like, "You gotta read this book."
He always had it in his hands.
He always had it like next to his journal
and he was talking about it constantly
and he gave it to me and Sacha,
this was around the time where Sacha was having
his first real big success as a screenwriter.
He had written the screenplay for "The Terminal"
which Steven Spielberg directed
with Tom Hanks.
Ah, yeah, uh huh.
So it must've been maybe, it was around 2000.
2002 is when "The War of Art"
came out, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Maybe a little bit later than that,
I can't remember exactly.
He lent me his copy and it just, it blew my mind.
It blew my mind.
And the idea that you could put a face and place,
a shape on this idea of resistance and start
to think about strategies and tactics
for tackling it was revelatory for me
and it really just unlocked something inside
of me that led me on this path
and empowered me to write "Finding Ultra"
and to start this podcast and to do all the things
that I do today.
Yeah, uh huh, wow.
So, thank you for that.
All right.
Yeah.
You're welcome.
(both laughing)
It's gotta be, obviously I'm not the only one
who's said something like that to you.
This work has been profoundly impactful
on so many people which places
you squarely in the seat of the kind of guru role and so,
I'm interested in how that lands
for you as somebody who's a practitioner,
a writer and that's your thing, right?
Ah, yes, that's a really interesting question, Rich.
It's like, I wrote "The War of Art" in like two months.
It just kinda came out of me like that
and it really is something that I sort of had done verbally
maybe 20 or 30 times with friends.
Friends would come to me and say,
"I know I've got a book in me.
Can you talk to me and help me?"
Da da da da.
And I'd sit up with 'em 'til two in the morning
kinda telling 'em there's this force out there,
this negative force called resistance
and the first thing you're gonna have
to do is overcome it before you can do anything else
and I would try to psych people up to do their thing
and of course nobody ever did it, right?
But so, I thought,
Right.
let me just write this book.
And then when someone comes to me like that I'll just say,
"Here, read this."
And I never, at the time, it took awhile
for it to kinda catch on.
And then people started writing to me
and kind of asking and putting me in the role of a mentor
or something like that,
which I really am not comfortable with and don't,
and from time to time people have said,
"You could take this on the road.
You could do-"
This could be your whole life.
"You could do this."
Right.
And I said, "Absolutely, I do not wanna,
I am a writer, I'm writing fiction.
This is what I wanna do and what
I've been trying to do my whole life."
And so, I've always feel uncomfortable with that.
To me, the best way of communicating what's in that book
is through a book.
And when I talk about it,
I'm never quite comfortable doing that.
I mean I'm happy
Yeah.
to do it with you if you will,
for your listeners.
Yeah, and we're definitely
gonna do that.
Definitely gonna do that today.
But I think what you're keying into there
is the fact that a core thesis
of the book is this idea of self-empowerment,
like you have to be
your own guru, right?
Yes, yes.
You have to take agency and control
over this path that you're blazing for yourself
and it's not about a guru or a teacher
and when you become the locus of all that energy,
that's really antagonistic to the ideas
that are set forth in the book itself.
Yeah, I'm sure you get this too, Rich.
Like when somebody puts you in the role of a guru
or a mentor or somebody that's looking for advice,
and I've done this myself on the other side.
They're giving away their power,
and when I've done it from the other side,
I can feel I'm giving away my power.
Why am I asking this guy or this gal what to do?
What do they know about me?
And one of the things that I,
people sometimes write me long emails talking
about their addiction or whatever it is,
whatever their issues are, right?
And what I've finally kinda come to say to people
is sit down and get into a kind of a calm place
and then read that note over yourself
as if somebody else had written it to you
'cause almost always within these kind
of expressions of self-loathing or agony,
the answer's right, it's just leaping right out of the page
that some project that they wanna do,
some book they wanna write or whatever it is,
and of course that's been my story too,
and the reason I wrote about resistance
was 'cause it was such a force in my life
and wiped me out for so many years.
Right, right.
So, we're gonna get into that 'cause it's pretty good.
We're brought to you today by The Plantpower Meal Planner
because I think we all aspire to eat better,
but most of us struggle when it comes
to how to make it stick.
So, we created a platform that takes all the hassle
and the guesswork out of optimal nutrition
by giving you affordable access
to thousands of customizable, delicious,
easy to prepare plant-based recipes
that are constantly being updated,
built in with automatic grocery delivery
of everything you need plus access
to our team of amazing nutrition coaches
ready to answer all your questions seven days a week.
To learn more and sign up, visit meals.richroll.com,
and right now we are offering a special deal.
$10 off an annual membership when you've used
the promo code RRHEALTH.
For just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com.
Let's define resistance kind of broadly
in the context of how you came to think of it.
I call it Resistance with a capital R
and like if we had a typewriter or a keyboard
in front of me now or you've got one there
with a blank screen or a blank page in it,
we would feel a force radiating off that page,
a negative force, trying to push you away from it, right?
And it would take, that's what I call resistance.
It would be the same thing as
if we went out and bought an exercise bike or a treadmill
and we brought it home to the house and,
"Oh, we're gonna," and suddenly we realize
we're coming up with every excuse
in the world not to get on that treadmill.
So, resistance is this negative force
of self-sabotage that will work against us
anytime we try to move from a lower level
to a higher level, ethically, morally, creatively.
If you have an idea for a book,
if you have an idea for a podcast,
if you have an idea for this studio
or something that you wanna do,
and I wanna ask you about this, Rich,
a voice will come into your head immediately
that will say, "Who are you to put this thing together?
This has been done a billion times
and it's been done better
than you ever could do or ever would do.
You're too old, you're too young,
you're too fat, you're too skinny.
You don't have enough education,
you have too much education," et cetera, et cetera.
And that negative force is universal.
I can tell you from the thousands
of emails I've got and not only is it universal,
but it's the same voice in every, in all of our heads.
It may be tailored a little bit to you or to me,
but it's the same voice.
And I was never aware of that.
When I first started to write as a 24 year old,
resistance just kicked my ass all over the place
and I went through a lotta stuff
before I finally kinda said to myself, you know what?
There's a force out there that's workin' against me.
It's not just something I'm inventing.
There is a real force out there just like gravity,
just like the transit of Venus across the sky.
And once I could sort of give a name to it,
then I could say, "Okay, now I have something
I can deal with.
How can I overcome this?
Can I develop habits that will help me overcome it?
Can I organize my day in such a way?
Can I change my mindset in such a way?"
And so, anyway, that's kind of my definition of resistance.
Well, the first step seems to be disassociating
your identity from the resistance itself
because I think what we all kinda do
is self identify with that.
That is part
of who we are, right?
That's a great way
to put it, Rich.
I've never heard that before.
That's exactly it.
Well, you have talked about
this idea that exists outside of yourself, right?
If you're just thinking, "Well, I can't do it."
This is me telling myself this,
as opposed to this external force
that we can define as this pernicious entity working
at odds with our effort to climb to that elevated place,
but what was it that was like the light switch
for you that allowed you to kind
of come to that realization?
Was it just pain?
It was pain, I guess, but I can't actually remember.
There was not like a moment when I said that
or if there was to myself, "Oh, this is resistance."
It just over time, I guess.
I mean, there was a moment that's sort
of where things turned around in that way for me,
but I don't think I identified a force as resistance,
but what you just said, Rich, is exactly right.
The disassociating this concept of resistance as fact
of resistance from your own identity.
Like when we hear this voice
in our head that says, "You're not good enough,
it's all been done," et cetera, et cetera,
what makes that so powerful against us
is we think it's our own thoughts.
We think, "Oh, that's me assessing
the situation objectively," but it's not.
It's this other siren voice,
this force that's just out there, that's a fact of nature.
And once we can say, "Oh, that's not me,"
that kind of is the key to the whole thing.
Right.
(chuckles) It's so interesting.
I think the other thing that happens
or I should just share my own personal experience
'cause I don't know what other people's experiences are,
but there's this sense that this is not something
that other people have to deal with.
There are the talented people out there,
those that are touched or those for whom,
the muse seems to come easy that are able
to sidestep this issue of dealing with resistance
and when you read the book and you realize,
oh, this is a universality, this is a universal thing.
This is something that everybody experiences
whether you're a writer, an entrepreneur, an athlete,
and also that it never goes away,
which is sort of disheartening,
but also comforting in the sense that I'm not alone.
Like, I tend to look at the world
and think everybody is figuring things out
in a way that I'm not able to, which leads to that voice
of self defeatism and that cycle then feeling bad
about myself for feeling self defeated
and the vicious cycle
Yeah, exactly.
that ensues that just takes you
down the shame spiral where paralysis
becomes impossible to overcome.
In fact, let me ask you, Rich,
you were saying before that when you read "The War of Art"
it made an impact on you.
What form did resistance take
for you at that particular time?
And what did
you do about it?
Well, I mean,
when I was writing "Finding Ultra,"
I mean, I'd never written a book before,
so the idea
Ah.
that I could even write
a book seemed daunting
Ah.
to say the least.
What is it that I could possibly share
that hasn't been said before?
I'm not an Olympic champion.
I've never won a race.
It's not like I'm the most amazing athlete in the world
and my story of addiction and recovery is pretty pedestrian.
Like, so, I would like, think why am I doing this?
Who could possibly be interested in this?
And the more they-
Yet, the book is fascinating and totally riveted me.
It was like a seminal book
Well, I appreciate that.
on my bookshelf.
And I tried to,
I don't know if you noticed,
but I dropped in little "War of Art" references,
not explicitly, but this idea of,
when your heart is true the universe
will conspire to support you or the prize
doesn't go to the fastest, it goes to the guy
who slows down the least.
Like the fairy dust that gets sprinkled
on top of the discipline and the patience
and the persistence and all the things that you speak
about that are required to achieve something excellent.
But it was really by dent of, of relying on the principles
in the book that allowed me to disassociate
from those negative voices
and just continue to plow through.
But I will say this, and I've said this
on the podcast before.
So, I wrote "Finding Ultra" in 2012.
I've done cookbooks and I have "Voicing Change"
and all of that and those are,
technically those books but they're not book books.
Right?
Yes, yes.
And I would say that the resistance
has never been stronger
for me in terms of writing what would
be considered a follow-up to "Finding Ultra"
or another book book.
And in many ways, this entire podcast venture
is like the most colossal form of resistance
that I've self erected
to create an excuse
Ah.
for not having to write a book.
And so, I've doven into this thing
and it's become very successful and gratifying
and I love it and it's amazing,
but it's fairly all consuming
and now it makes it easier for me to tell myself,
"Well, I don't have time to write another book
or do I even really need to?
I reach more people on this microphone every week
then a book that's gonna take me a year
and a half to write."
So, why do it, right?
So, that resistance,
Ah.
and this is another thing
But that of course is
like the resistance
the absolute voice
never goes away.
of resistance.
It basically fills whatever vacancy
that you have in your life and adapts
to whatever environment you're in to prevent
you from accessing that next level of higher consequence.
So you didn't have any resistance
to the podcast tonight, to do the podcast?
Well, because that's like
a procrastination or a distraction.
In certain respects you can
Yes, I know what you mean.
make it harder but, yeah.
So, I should be writing right now
You gotta write that
instead of talking to you
in the book, yeah, yeah.
about writing (laughs).
But yeah, so the resistance takes many forms
and to this point of the tactile and the mystical,
another thing that I really love about it
is that what you write about is so rooted
in very practical takeaways,
like, look you gotta create ritual,
you gotta create habits,
you've gotta be your own self disciplinary
and you have to have these rules
and here's how you set up your calendar
and erect healthy boundaries to protect that thing
that's most precious to you.
But when you do those things, you provide the space
for the muse to enter and for you to connect
with the collective unconscious
so that you are not necessarily writing
or whatever it is you're creating,
but really acting as a channel for the best version
of who you are to reveal itself to you.
Right.
So, talk a little bit
about that balance between the practical and the mystical.
Well, that's absolutely true
and this must be in Ultra fitness events too.
I mean, when you write about this,
that it's when you get to that point of
the third day of running around Hawaii or whatever it is,
your third Ironman in Hawaii,
that you start getting really deeply into yourself, right?
You're in a whole other level,
but the way that you get there
is through the mundane, through the training
and through one foot in front of another
and all of the discipline
and the ritual that goes into that.
But it is, the creative process to me,
this is my experience,
is that it's a two-sided thing.
On the one hand, there is the practical,
the blue collar aspect of the thing.
You have to show up every morning,
you have to have habits that reinforce what you're doing.
You have to work every day,
just like a blue collar guy with a whistle, the factory,
but at the same time, once you sort of get rolling
and it's really like yoga, right?
Where the whole concept of yoga
is that you use the body to get to the spirit, right?
To, as you get deeper and deeper and deeper
into a particular pose, things start to happen inside you.
And the same thing, certainly in writing
and songwriting and things like that,
that once the mundane has been taken care of,
the floor has been swept, the table's been cleaned
and you're actually shutting down,
the hour, one hour, two hour three,
and you know this, Rich, pretty soon things start to happen.
Ideas start coming to you.
There is a muse, there is a higher level and your intention
and your integrity and your work, your labor, your sweat,
to go for that higher level gets rewarded.
And the higher level does come down to you
and it's a commonplace to say
that the best pages I've ever written,
I don't remember writing them at all.
And that's not completely true
because you are kind of there, you're doing your thing.
It isn't just a magical thing
but you get there through the depth
of commitment and of aspiration and of intensity.
And another thing while I'm blathering
on here about this stuff
is that-
No, I love it.
Keep goin'.
That one of the things that I hate about this era today,
the internet era, the social media era
is it's so surface, it's so superficial.
It rewards absolute superficiality, right?
We go from one clickbait thing to another,
we never delve into anything.
And if there isn't a secret to creativity
or to Ultra fitness or anything like that, it's depth.
It's the opposite.
It's kind of after hour one is different
than after 10 minutes and after hour two
is different than after hour one and so on.
If you're, as a writer, as you start getting
into a scene or something that you're working on,
as you get level, level, level down, things start coming.
You just, and it's not even mystical.
It's just sorta like,
well, gee that guy that I had standing in the corner,
that guy should come out here and say something, you know?
And then oh my God, that really makes it happen.
Whereas you wouldn't have thought
of that the first 10 minutes into the operation.
Yeah, you gotta blast out all the cobwebs
and create that open space that allows for that
to come in and as a writer that's what you live for.
So, the structure, the rigor that you put in
and the discipline is solely to create
that open space for those glimpses
to enter, right?
Yeah, exactly.
And that's true.
Like, when I first read "The War of Art",
the culture was very different.
Now, the level to which we're enticed
by distraction is 1,000 fold what it was a decade ago,
let alone two decades ago
which I think in some regard
makes your work more urgent, right?
If we can identify an optimistic vein
in all of this it's that we're becoming more aware
of how distracted we are at the same time
that we've become more powerless
to defend against it,
That's right, right.
but we're having conversations about that
and we're having conversations with our kids
about that because we feel ourselves being pulled
into our phones in a way that we realize
is alarming and it's become incumbent upon
all of us to exert a little bit more,
a lot more self-discipline around what's important
to ourselves so that we can carve that out.
And for many, for most, and I found myself in this place,
it's a losing battle.
You're competing with computer engineers
who've studied psychology and know exactly what to dangle
in front of you to keep you on that lower plane
and prevent you from ascending to your potential.
I've always said if resistance is a real force and it is,
and it's out there, I always have said,
if you wanna make $1,000,000,000,
invent something that lets people yield
to their resistance and the internet
and social media, that's it, they invented it.
Everything that we want, the distraction that's
put in front of us, the clickbait that's put in front of us
feeds into this existing force that's there already,
that wants to distract us from our own,
whatever our own calling is inside here.
And so, I don't think there's any real way around it
other than to sort of block it out somehow,
just turn it off, go away from it somehow.
I don't think you can dally in that world and defeat it.
It's too powerful.
Right, right.
But you've, I mean, you're on social media
and you've got this website that's pretty robust
and educational and it's got tons of content
and you've did this video series
on the warrior ethos that's up there.
So, you're participating but I suspect
that you have pretty good rules
around when you engage
and when you disengage.
That's true but I'm also
a little bit like what you were sayin' about the podcast.
That stuff is a little easier to do
and I actually need to crack the whip over myself.
I've got a book that's waiting to go
and that I'm kind of-
We're gonna talk about it.
avoiding at the moment too.
So-
Yeah, oh, another one
that you're workin' on right now?
Yeah, another one I'm workin' on now.
Yeah.
Uh huh.
Well, I heard you talk about this as well.
Something that's unique to the culture
at the moment that is new and different
from our predecessors is this idea that everybody
has to now kind of think of themselves as a brand, right?
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're all like
what is my avatar
and what do I represent
Yeah, yeah.
on the internet and how am I communicating
with other people?
And beneath that, I suppose,
is this idea of individualism, right?
As opposed to collectivism.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The great generation,
they weren't thinking about themselves
as brands or what their individual identity was.
They got on a career track and they held
that job for their entire professional career
whereas now we're switching between careers all the time
and it's really about like, what's in my best interest?
And there's a lot of not so great things about that
but one thing I think, and I've heard you speak about this
that is interesting and somewhat optimistic
is that it does sorta compel you
to ask these questions about who you are.
Like you're having this dialogue
with the internal voice
about what it is that you're here to do,
what it is that you're here to express.
Yeah, the whole concept now
of everybody having to be a brand and what is my,
I don't know exactly
It's like so bad.
where that goes.
But as you say, it's a little bit like the Maslow pyramid,
where at the bottom you're just dealing
with your basic needs of food, shelter, whatever
and by the time you get to the tippy top
you're into self-realization and the concept
of who am I, why am I here?
That kinda thing.
And we're lucky enough now in this world
of as bad as things are,
at least we don't have to go out
and kill what we need to eat.
A lot of us are at the top or near the top
of that pyramid or have the time to do that
and we start asking these questions of,
which is what "The War of Art's" all about
is really who am I, what is my gift?
The actors question, the standard,
who am I, why am I here, what do I want?
And in a way, what's the point of human life
if we don't ask that question?
What is particular gift?
What is mine?
What are your kids gift?
Whatever.
But I'm not sure where it goes in this world of hyper,
can everybody be a brand?
Can everybody have some,
be trying to buy other people's books or movies?
I don't know, but I sort of,
I was just talking about this yesterday,
the concept of, to go to the ancient world a little,
in Pericles' Funeral Oration back in ancient Athens
where he talks about the idea of a citizen
and that he says that, "I declare of our citizens of Athens
that they are the," what was the, how did he say it?
"The rightful Lord and owner of his own person."
And as opposed to being a serf or a slave
or somebody that's in a mass movement
or is a cult or is being,
somebody else is guiding them,
and I think that it is incumbent upon all
of us to get to that point where we are
the rightful Lord and owner of our own person.
And at that point, the next question is how do we do that
in a community for the good of the whole planet
and for future generations and not just our own brand
and what we can sell,
and how many t-shirts we could sell, whatever.
So, it's certainly not good to be blind to that,
to be unaware of that,
but we're sort of at a point now where
we're at that tippy top of the pyramid
where we're maybe more obsessed
with that then is healthy.
And yeah, at what cost?
No longer are we facing a death sentence
for laying down our shield.
We have lost that connection
with the collective wellbeing, right?
It's all about like,
Yes.
what I need and what I want.
We see this being played out with
the wars over wearing masks and not wearing masks.
And I fear for the cohesion of the greater comedy
when that's the only question being asked.
Yeah.
I mean, maybe it's good in a sense that we're,
like you say, we're having to deal with it.
We're becoming aware of it now
where we weren't aware of it before.
I mean, I do think in America
if you could ask the average bear,
they do want to come together.
I think people do want this country
to be unified one way or another,
at least to think of each other,
not as the devil or the enemy,
but we just are not sure how.
We're so polarized and tribalized at the moment.
Yeah.
Well, I mean, that brings up,
I was gonna get to this later
but it seems like a good time to talk about it now,
as somebody who is so well versed and steeped in all
of these ancient cultures, the warrior cultures,
somebody who has written lots of military novels,
how do you take all of that tremendous research
that you've done over the years
that has seeped into all of your books?
How does that impact how you think
about where we're at right now, culturally and politically?
Well, that's a tough one.
We certainly see a lot of people now who,
it seems to me, have abandoned the idea
of honor or integrity.
And I'm not sure how that happened but if we think back,
like, my dad was in World War II.
that was The Greatest Generation, you know?
And there, there definitely was a concept
that a man acts in a certain way and a woman too, right?
That there are certain levels
that you won't allow yourself to sink to.
You just won't go those places.
But somehow in this culture today,
we're plumbing new depths of these, new depths.
Shame is a great thing that,
the ancient Spartans were a shame-based culture.
And the Japanese, the samurai is a shame-based culture
where there were certain things that you just would not do.
You would not go,
you would you die before that would happen, right?
If you were a samurai you would kill yourself
before you would do that.
And I don't know, maybe you have an answer to this, Rich.
I don't know what happened
to the idea of shame and where people
are now so shameless that nothing is beneath them.
I mean, we had a president that was plumbing
new depths of shamelessness every day
and it seemed to be like his superpower in some way.
And I don't know, what do you think about that, Rich?
What happened?
Yeah, I mean,
certainly, I don't know
that I have any great insight into that
but I think shame has been trumped by the drive
for attention and what drives attention is drama
and strife and pettiness
and all those sorts
I guess that's, yeah.
of things, right?
That come at the cost of comporting yourself
in a more virtuous manner.
Yeah, I guess if you're willing to put a sex tape
on Instagram or whatever where they put it,
that maybe you'll start getting attention.
Not you and me, but certain people out there.
Right.
So, I guess
that's a big part of it that if you discard shame,
you can get more attention
by just acting in more of a shameless way,
doing things that nobody ever did before.
And people will look at that,
"Oh my God, look at how they did that."
Right, but when I see that,
what I think is that person
is blind to living an examined life, right?
Which is really at the core
of what your work is.
Yes.
I mean, you say there is a war afoot,
that war is between you and you
and you're the enemy, right?
Like, the only that exists
is the war between you and you.
And it's your job to raise your sword and go to battle
with yourself for the purpose of reaching that higher state
of consciousness or elevating yourself
and connecting with the more authentic,
true self within so that you can bring expression
to what it is that makes you uniquely you
and share those gifts with the world.
So, talk a little bit about that war with the self.
It's "The War of Art" for me.
That's why the title of the book.
And I believe that we're all born with a destiny.
We're all born with an identity like Wordsworth's poem,
"Not trailing clouds of glory
do we come from God who is..."
We come into this life with
an already established identity whether,
now, I don't believe in previous lives but I don't wanna,
we don't wanna go down that rabbit hole today
but at any rate,
We can go down it
I do think that we,
but go ahead.
if you have kids, from day one,
one is different from another, right?
They've got an identity and it's there, right?
Even kittens and puppies are that way, right?
So, we have this identity,
but then there, that is kind of crying
out like an acorn to become an oak, right?
And we have this identity
but we don't know what it is.
It's sort of a trick that life plays on us, right?
We come in and we don't know who we are.
And adolescence is like the excruciating moment
of not knowing what we are, right?
And then again, there is this force of resistance
that when we try to ask that question of ourselves,
who am I, what do I love, what is my gift?
This force of resistance will try
to stop us from examining it.
It'll try to distract us.
It'll try to push us off in a shadow careers
or shadow activities or something that's not in that way.
And so, this is the war that we're fighting
is against that negative force
to find out who we are and what our gift is.
I mean, I always say that I think I've written
like 20 books now, which is kind of amazing to me
since my first book came out when I was 55, right?
Right, that's so crazy.
And it's absolutely true
that before I wrote any one of those books
I had no clue that I was gonna write that book.
Not like, it wasn't like I was sitting,
"Oh, I've got this whole magazine of books,"
like bullets in a magazine waiting to go.
I had no idea at all.
So, but the point of that is
that we find out who we are by the works that we produce.
And so, but yet, those works as they come along
are mysteries to us.
We don't know, where's it coming from?
I never would have thought, if you would look at
the list at the front of a book of mine,
of this title, that title, the other title,
never would have thought,
"Oh, that's coming next or that's..."
It's a mystery to me.
So again, that is sort of the war of going forward
into the unknown and kind of following the muse,
following whatever other, whatever goddess,
whatever is coming from another dimension,
that song that's playing
in your head when you're on the freeway
that nobody else has heard.
That's the war going and fighting that
and you're fighting it against your own self,
against your own self-sabotage that's trying to stop you.
So that is, to me, that's kind of the coming into
who you were already.
You already were that, but you just didn't know it.
And through these actions, you realize it and you go,
"Wow, I had no idea I was gonna have a podcast.
I had no idea I was gonna
be talking to 587 people and writing "Finding Ultra"
and "Finding Ultra Part Two."
I had no,"
We'll see.
or whatever else is out there.
Right, but it's in the doing, right?
The waging of the war
is action-based, right?
Yes.
Whereas I think a lotta people are,
maybe they're pursuing some self inquiry
but it's an intellectual exercise
and they're sort of awaiting the epiphany,
the sort of descending idea
of who they are before they actually do anything.
And by your description and the books that you've written,
it's the process that reveals, right?
You have to engage with that process
and wrestle with it and it is in that,
that you have these discoveries.
Exactly, and I think for me,
I can tell you that I spent many years
in that world inside my head wasting my time.
It's like therapy.
It's like going there, it's like yammer, yammer, yammer.
But until you actually start to, once you start to act,
like I'm sure it's the same in Ultra fitness
or anything like that, once you actually start,
then you start to discover things, right?
Then you start to-
The path unfolds
in front of you.
It does.
Slowly.
After-
Not easily.
Yeah, the idea of being that,
what paralyzes many is they wanna see
what that path looks like, or at least,
be able to forecast pretty forecast pretty far down
the line before they take the first step
and it just doesn't work that way.
You have to take those steps not knowing
and trust that the brick will get laid right,
one step in front of you as you go.
Yeah, and it is scary.
I mean, it is the unknown that we're going through,
we're going into, and it's scary.
There's no doubt about it.
Right.
And part of that war is the battle
between that instinct, that seed that I think
does live within of us that's telling us
there's something you're here to do.
I don't know what it is, but it's kind
of like this little faint voice in the back
of your mind and then the increasing self-loathing
or toxicity that creeps up
the more that you ignore that voice,
right?
Yes.
Until it becomes more painful to not do it,
Right, until-
unless you do it.
Yeah, it's like, until those things cross
and you really have what I think
is akin to somebody who's hit their bottom
with drugs and alcohol.
I think it's exactly that.
Yeah.
Where the pain
of the status quo exceeds the fear
of that unknown path ahead.
Yes, I think it's exactly that.
And I do think that we have to kind of hit bottom
in some sense before we start
on any kind of upward course.
Because we're, resistance is so diabolical
and it puts us in denial of whatever it is,
like this particular book that I'm workin'
on right now that I'm starting on now,
I had the exact same thing that you were talking about
about "Finding Ultra 2," whatever it is,
or even "Finding Ultra" where I say to myself,
"Who's gonna care about this thing?
This is the dumbest idea.
You've established a certain reputation,
you're gonna destroy that reputation
if you write this thing.
It's so dumb.
Nobody's gonna possibly," et cetera, et cetera.
And I know that I sort of have to hit
some kind of bottom where I say,
"Look, I just can't stand this shit anymore.
I can't stand hearing this yammering in my head.
I just gotta do this damn thing."
Right, and it's funny, I'm laughing because
you're the guy who has all the self-awareness around this
and yet you're still (laughs)-
But it's true
Finding yourself
for everybody, right?
in that place.
Everybody does it.
Right.
Well, let's go back.
You've led such a interesting, colorful life.
I mean, did you, as a young person
did you always know that you wanted to be a writer?
I mean, you have this period of your life
of essentially being like this blue collar journeyman
with all these different, crazy jobs.
Yeah, no, I never, as a young person, never.
And sort of the gist of the start of that thing
I think you may have heard this story before,
but I was workin' as a copywriter
at an ad agency in New York.
And I had a boss named Ed Hannibal
who quit and wrote a novel and the novel was a hit.
Overnight he was like a success
and he quit and went off,
and I thought to myself, "Well, shit, why don't I do that?
No problem."
So, that was the first time that I thought of,
"Oh, I could write,"
or that aspiration-
It seemed possible.
seemed possible to where never
did it even cross my mind before.
And did you immediately go home and start writing
or how did that begin to play out in your life?
Pretty much.
I sort of, I did quit my job and I was married.
I was livin' in New York City and I kind of set out
to write this thing and I had no business whatsoever.
I had no clue what writing was, no idea what resistance was,
no concept of any of the things,
and I worked on it for about two years,
got this close to the end
and Resistance with a capital R, I just blew up my life.
I couldn't face that last one yard
to get across the goal line and just acted out
in ways that we don't need to talk about
but that sort of blew that whole thing up.
And that kind of set me out in this kind of odyssey
of traveling around the country and workin'
these crazy jobs that I worked.
Right.
So, you blow up your marriage,
you blow up the book in this colossal act
of self-sabotage and really fear, right?
Was it fear of success?
Absolutely, terror, terror.
Fear of failure?
Like there are all kind
Both.
of close cousins of, there's subsets of resistance.
There's resistance, self-sabotage is an aspect of that
but why does self-sabotage become so prominent?
And what is the fear that you think drives that?
At least for yourself?
I mean, I think
it's like I said,
it's the fear of going
from a lower level to a higher level.
Fear of success in other words.
If I had finished that book,
no matter how bad it was,
I would have gone to a higher level.
I would have been a guy who at least wrote a book
at age 24 or whatever I was at that time.
And of course I was completely unconscious of all this,
no clue what was goin' on.
All I knew was I was in a state of terror
and I had to kind of get out of it one way or another.
If I had been an alcoholic,
I would have just drunk and wound up in the ditch somewhere.
Right, right, right (laughs).
So you just, you implode your whole life
because that's safer than what might happen if you actually
finish the book.
Yeah, yeah.
And I think that speaks
to just how powerful the resistance is, right?
Yes.
And what an unconscious driver
it can be.
Yes.
So then you go off across America holding all this.
You worked in a mental institution,
you worked on a farm, you did all kinds of stuff,
right?
Yeah.
And writing along the way
or what was the relationship to writing during
that period of time?
No, I mean,
it was really a state of running away from it.
So, I kept, I had my, I lived in my van.
I had a '65 Chevy van that I went back
and forth across the country 13 times in,
and I always had my typewriter with me,
but I never touched it.
It was like under, I don't know what, a shirt,
it was wrapped in something or another,
but I was just absolutely running away from that.
But I didn't know it.
If you had asked me, I wouldn't have said,
I'd have to come up with some excuse,
some bogus rationalization.
But on some deep level, I knew, I knew that...
I sort of said to myself, "This was a terrible mistake
I made trying to write in the first place.
I never should have done it.
It was really stupid."
But on some other level I knew this is what,
I gotta come back to this somehow.
I gotta slay this dragon somehow or it's gonna kill me.
Right, well, otherwise you woulda just gone back
and worked at the ad agency, right?
Why did you just,
Yeah.
light off onto the terrain,
in this sort of Mark Twain kinda way (laughs)?
Well, we're getting into some deep stuff here, Rich,
but what happened was maybe you can relate
to this from your own experiences.
I remember I had an interview.
I did try to go back to an ad agency.
I had an interview with a guy that I had worked with before
who would become a boss, blah, blah, blah.
And when I went in to that interview,
I must have stunk with such loserdom
or whatever it was that I was like toxic
and I could see in people's eyes that they saw this on me.
And it was like, "Get this guy outta here," whatever it is.
And I had a couple of more things like that.
Didn't take many to do that
and I just realized somehow I had fallen out
of the bottom of the middle-class.
You know how, if you've been to college
and you can speak with polysyllabic words
you would go into a room and people,
"Oh, this is one of us," et cetera.
For whatever reason, I had kinda fallen through
the bottom of it and the reason that I worked
a bunch of blue collar jobs
is not like it was any plan of mine.
It was like, those were the only jobs I could get.
Hm, interesting.
So yeah, I just kinda fell through the floor.
The floor opened up and I went through the trap door.
Went through the bottom.
And so you're kinda goin' from gig to gig,
got the typewriter, refuse to get rid of it
even though you're not using it.
So, walk me up to the point where the pain of this reality
that you were experiencing just became too much
and you kind of have this tipping point.
Actually, I write about this in "The War of Art",
but let me, I'll tell you one other little story
before we get to that.
After, I don't know how many years it was,
it was only maybe three or four years.
It wasn't like an endless amount of time
of going around the country,
I finally, I just kinda gave up on that whole life.
I know I'm goin' on here.
No, no, no, go.
But one of the concepts I had in my mind came
from Jack Kerouac's book, "On the Road,"
and from the whole, this was kinda
the '60s and the early '70s.
And I felt like if I could get myself
to this mystical place,
I could be someone that could walk
in anywhere to any situation, I could relate to it,
I could find work, I could make friends, da da da da,
if I could just get
to that place instead of being so stuck
in my own head and so afraid and all that sorta stuff.
And that was kinda my ideal.
And at some point, I was actually in San Francisco,
and I was down to getting a job as a driving instructor.
And for me, that was like the lowest
'cause I had driven trucks.
I had done, somehow driving was my thing
for whatever it was.
And I just gave up.
I said, "I can't do this.
I'm not Jack Kerouac.
I can't live this life on the road.
I'm just, I give up.
I'm goin' home.
I'm goin' back to New York.
I'm gonna take the shittiest job I can find
and I'm gonna try to little by little kind of work
my way back into the middle-class however I could."
And I was driving across the country back to New York,
taking the Southern route and I met this couple,
a cowboy and his wife who had just gotten married
and they had all their possessions
in a paper bag between 'em.
And the short version of the story was
we kinda became friends over a couple of days
and he said, "I'm goin' to be workin' on my uncle's ranch.
Why don't you come with me?"
And I said, "I can't ride a horse.
I don't want anything about that."
"I'll teach ya, no problem."
And I thought to myself, "Hm, a cowboy.
I've never been a cowboy.
Maybe I should try..."
And I just said to myself, "I can't do this anymore.
I can't do this anymore.
I've just gotta go home."
So, I did go home and to keep blathering along here, Rich,
there's a chapter in "The War of Art"
where I talk about this.
I got back to New York, I got a job drivin' a cab
and I was in a job tending bar
and I had a little sublet apartment.
And one night I was just, I was sitting there and I went
into that sort of what I imagined an alcoholic goes
into when they really need a drink.
And I just thought, I thought,
"Who could I call?
Are there any women I could call
that I could kind of go over to their place
or is there somebody I could,"
just, and I said to myself, "I just can't do this anymore,"
and I pulled out that typewriter.
And like I say, this is in "The War of Art,"
and I sat down for like two hours, just typing some story.
I don't know what it was.
Whatever it was I threw it away.
It was terrible, right?
And I went into wash, there was some dishes in the sink.
And as I started washing the dishes,
I realized that I was whistling and I sort of had
this sense that like I was okay.
Then I thought, "Oh, I can sit down at the typewriter.
I'm like a million miles from doing anything good,
but finally I can actually sit and try,"
and like this great weight went
off my shoulders at that point and I thought,
"It may take me another 30 years,"
which it did to do anything decent
but at least I can do it now and I don't know why
I could when I couldn't before.
Maybe because I'd tried everything else
under the sun.
Right, right.
And I just knew I couldn't try that anymore.
Right.
What was your self-awareness
around that moment at the time?
Nothing more than what I just told you.
I just felt like, I now can sit at a typewriter
and try to work and I'm gonna be okay.
I'm not gonna fall off the end of the earth.
I'm not gonna go insane.
I'm gonna be okay.
Right.
To extend the alcoholic analogy,
I mean, there's so many similarities.
It's sorta like the alcoholic trying everything
before finally just giving up
and raising their hand and saying, "I need help," right?
"I'm gonna drink only after five o'clock.
I'm only gonna drink beer."
You have to do all of that and exhaust
all of it before you're so depleted
and ready for something new, like that change.
And in your situation, taking all of these different jobs,
it would be one thing if you were a truck driver,
a cowboy, whatever, if that was part of the plan
of collecting amazing experiences to write about
but that wasn't what you were doing.
These were just,
No, absolutely not.
you were just running away from your life,
essentially.
Yeah.
Now you must look back and think,
"Oh, I've got all these rich experiences
that I can tap into.
I do think those experiences were important
even though I haven't actually ever tapped
into those specific ones.
But if I look, I'm a believer in the muse,
I believe there's a goddess up there.
And if I think of the muse
like watching over me at this time,
she would say, "Oh, look at him
go down this blind alley."
Right, right.
"Look at him go down that blind alley."
And then finally, when I come back and I sit down
at the typewriter, I think she finally perks up and goes,
"Ah, the son of a bitch is finally sitting down
and doin' what I've been waiting
for him to do for all this time."
And now from the goddesses point of view she would say,
"Okay, I'm gonna give him something.
I'm gonna give him an idea.
I've been holding back.
Now, I'm gonna help him a little bit."
Right.
I mean, there is a divinity in being that broken and-
Definitely.
And something to be revered about hitting bottom.
And it's something that I think about a lot
'cause I'm involved in the recovery community.
It's like, do you step in and try to divert somebody
from meeting that kind of predicament?
Or is that exactly what they need?
I mean, I know in my own case, I've had a couple bottoms
and they were transformational and I look back
on them with great gratitude.
There was so much pain
that I don't wanna ever experience that again.
But they were the catalyst
for the greatest growth experiences that I've ever had.
So, there is something to be said
for standing back and being the observer,
as opposed to-
Yeah, instead
of letting somebody be in a box.
Yeah, yeah.
Which is one of the things I really loved
about "Finding Ultra" that that really came through.
That was absolutely, as I said,
that's for real, that's the real thing.
Yeah, I still wish it hadn't happened, but yeah.
I mean, you can't shortcut somebody's growth trajectory
and that applies to the pursuit
of art and creativity as well, right?
Like something that I really appreciate
about what you talk about and write about
is the fact that there is no hack here, right?
Like we're in this culture where everybody's looking
for the shortcut
and how can I,
Yeah, exactly.
eradicate all the pain and just
get right to the good stuff?
And it just doesn't work that way.
And rather than fighting that, just embrace that
because that's part of the toil and the joy that contributes
to what it is that you're trying to express.
It's so hard to do though, to keep doin' that stuff.
But I remember one moment I was workin'
in the oil fields in Louisiana,
and I had this friend that,
we lived in this little bunkhouse together, and his brother,
he had an older brother who had also gone
through one of these odysseys, right?
And he was tellin' me that,
my friend was tellin' me one day
that his brother had finally like gotten out of it.
He got married, everything was good.
And I said, "Well, how old is he now?"
And I forgot what the age was,
but it was like 18 years old.
God, our age.
I said, "Oh, shit, you mean we gotta
go through this for another 18 years?"
But, I mean, as an entertainment lawyer
being in the movie business
and knowing all that you know about
the all is lost moment which is the,
like in any story you always gotta sort of take that,
your character, the protagonist,
to that moment
Right, you gotta get
where they hit bottom,
to the bottom
right?
of the second act.
And at that point, then they can start to come up
and it's a cliche of movies and of stories,
but it's life, it's real life.
Right.
The hero's journey.
Yeah.
That archetype is so powerful.
It obviously is front and center
in everything that you do and think about,
but what is it, like that,
why does that blueprint resonate so deeply
in an unconscious way?
Like, we understand it, we gravitate towards it.
We know it works in terms of storytelling
whether you're writing a novel
or a screenplay or a short story,
but it's interesting to try to ponder
from whence does that come?
Like, is it just bred into our DNA
as we evolved over the millennia?
That's what I think.
I think it is.
I think over the millennia from going there,
from hominids to cave men
and tribal things that life just sort
of works in a certain way, right?
And I do think it's software that we're born with,
that that model,
the hero's journey is encoded in whatever,
in our DNA, like along with the archetypes.
And it exerts an irresistible impulse
on us I think to live it out.
In one form or another,
I think we all have to have a hero's journey
or many hero's journeys, one after another.
And I think a lot of maybe what is going wrong today
in this country is people aren't living out
their hero's journey 'cause they,
somehow they don't have to,
it's not, life, it's easy enough now.
People can get by that they don't have to do that.
And also, obviously the force of resistance
is trying to stop them from doing that.
But I would, there's,
Walker Percy is a great kind of writing hero of mine
and he wrote a book, I'm blanking on the name of it now,
but in the book, it's not "The Moviegoer,"
the character is a doctor and he has
a couple that come to him and they're a married couple
and they're having struggles and they live
like 14 miles away on the other side of a swamp.
And he says, "Tonight, when you leave here,
go home through the swamp.
Don't drive home.
Leave your car here."
And he sort of compels them onto a hero's journey,
a little mini hero's journey through the swamp.
And of course they get home
and have the greatest sex they ever had (laughs),
but there's something to that,
that it's easier for us these days to kinda
go around the swamp and we don't even have
a kind of an aspiration or an ethic to go through the swamp.
It's not like that's, "Oh, you should do that."
It's you should avoid that.
Right, of course.
All the kind of cultural machinations point
us towards aspiring to a life of comfort, ease, and luxury.
And to go back to Maslow's hierarchy of needs,
if your needs are essentially met,
then it's just too simple to go
to your job and to lease the car
and get the takeout food, and watch Netflix,
and never step outside of that and challenge yourself.
And I think too many people, to echo Thoreau,
like end up "Leading these lives of quiet desperation"
because they're not consciously engaging
with that thing that I do believe is inside all of us,
that's yearning to be expressed, right?
Well, let me ask you this, Rich,
isn't kind of ultra endurance sports,
isn't that sort of about that?
Where you kind of, you don't have to do that.
You deliberately choose this adversity,
this real extreme adversity
and you deliberately choose to put yourself through that.
Isn't that kind of what it's about?
It's kind of a hero's journey?
Well, yeah,
because we're not living Telamon's life, right?
We are in this situation where you have
to craft that for yourself.
That's why you see
Yeah, artificially.
Spartan races and Ironman's and all of these things
because there is something deeply embedded inside of us
that seeks out that challenge
that is not presenting itself in our life
because our lives are too easy.
And I just, I don't know that when I first got involved
in ultra endurance I had conscious self-awareness
around that but something
was driving me in that direction.
But, and I write about this in "Finding Ultra,"
I mean, it was really a spiritual journey, not a physical.
Everyone's all the physicality of it
or it was a mental challenge,
but it was really a spiritual challenge.
And when I think of your work,
like I think of "Bagger Vance,"
and I think of the Bhagavad Gita
and I think of Krishna and Arjuna and that relationship
and Bagger's relationship and in the book,
and how the caddy is trying to get the master
to connect with that deepest part of who he is.
And that comes about only through the crucible
of challenge and the stripping away of all the artifice
that stands in between you and who you really are.
And in my context, it wasn't golf, it was ultra endurance
which is a, I didn't have a bagger telling me what to do,
but the sheer process
of undergoing such a difficult physical journey
was my means of stripping away all of that
so I could communicate with a different part of who I was.
And it worked.
It worked.
It was transformational.
And like I said, I didn't consciously know
that I was doing that at the time
in the same way that you weren't sure
what you were doing when you finally sat down
at the typewriter and banged out a few pages.
Yeah, I would say that the hero's journey embedded,
encoded in your DNA demanded to be lived out.
At least I'm sure you've had many others before that
but in this particular case, you were sort of drawn
to ultra endurance and maybe you didn't know why,
just like I've been drawn to things and I don't know why,
but I think it's that imperative that's inside us,
that instinct, why does a salmon swim upstream?
Or why do birds migrate across whatever it is?
I think it was something like that.
It was really the best part of you,
the best part of your soul I think calling
to you and saving your life and leading you
on this transformational journey that worked,
that actually created change.
It did work, but it was catalyzed by a bottom
and a tremendous amount of pain, right?
And short of somebody meeting their version
of that for themselves,
they're otherwise faced with this choice of living life
out in this "Matrix"-esque pre-programmed way
or choosing to bring adversity in their lives.
And that's difficult to do if you're not in pain.
Yes, yes.
Right?
Right.
So when somebody comes to you and says,
"I know I'm just not quite as fulfilled as I'd like to be,"
but they haven't really sunk to any kind
of traumatic depths, making that leap is more difficult
than the person who's really up against it.
Yeah, I think it's impossible
to make that-
You think it's impossible?
It's like the choice is always there.
That choice is available.
It is possible, but for some reason,
we're just not gonna grab it.
Until the pain reaches
unendurable levels.
Right (laughs)?
Yeah.
Why does it have
to be that way?
I don't know.
Why is-
The world would be better
if everybody could grab
onto that rope a little bit sooner, maybe.
Yeah.
I don't know.
This plays into the warrior ethos.
So, how do these two things like cohere for you?
Like the artist's life, the pursuit of creativity,
the grappling with the resistance,
the walking through the difficult things.
How does that match up
with how you think about the warrior path
and how that plays out in your novels
and you recently did this like series on your website
and on YouTube of talking about this?
Well, when my second book was "Gates of Fire"
which is about the 300 Spartans at Thermopylae,
not the book that the movie "300" came from.
A better version of that, which is taught at Annapolis
and at West Point
Yeah it's taught at various-
and places like that, right?
Because it's an expression of the warrior ethos.
But when that book could've,
like I said to you before, Rich,
I had no idea that book was coming.
No idea that I wanted to write it.
It just sort of appeared,
and I was seized by it and had to do it.
And I found myself writing
like the next four books were really sort of warrior books
about Alexander the Great, about the Amazon's,
about various other things and it was,
various other warrior cultures.
And it was a surprise to me.
It's like I say to myself,
"Well, why am I writing about this?"
It's not like, I'm not a Navy SEAL.
Why did I write about this?
And I think that it's the inner war, the writer's war,
the artist's war that we were talkin' about
that in a way you, to face the blank page,
to write a book, to write a movie, to write whatever it is,
or ultra endurance, things like that,
you have to be a warrior.
One way or another you've gotta take the warrior virtues
which I would name as courage, patience, comradery,
love for one's brothers and sisters, selflessness,
and very important, the willing embracing of adversity
and there are a lot of other virtues
but those virtues that a warrior, a Spartan warrior
or Alexander the Great would use it for enemies out there,
the artist or the endurance athlete uses
those virtues to get against the enemies in here, right?
When you're on your fourth Ironman in a row,
and every fiber of your being is screaming out,
"Stop, stop, this is insane,"
you're having to call upon something, right?
And I think it's that sort of, that warrior mentality,
the same thing that the Spartans called
on when the day three at Thermopylae, whatever.
So, I guess, again, I was sort of drawn to write these books
and I didn't even know why
but I think I was kind of reinforcing
for myself in a way that kind of code,
that code of honor, that sense of shame,
and that ability to kind of endure
and to keep going forward into into the unknown.
Yeah.
The idea of being regimented of having
a core code of ethics to which
you organize your life is what's required
to express yourself as an artist
which I think is anathema for somebody who's unfamiliar
because they think, "Oh, artists are just,
they're free thinking and they just create,
and it's all very flowery,"
Yeah, right, yeah.
whereas you've imposed almost a military discipline
and structure upon this process to demystify it
so that you can allow for the mystical to enter
and how that plays into what it means to be a warrior.
It's like the warriors,
the warrior's obstacles are external.
The artists' obstacles are internal,
but the warrior on the battlefield
has to have mastery over that sense of self,
that like interconnectedness in order
to combat those external forces of resistance.
Is that how you did that?
Yes, the other thing
is that I think in a military context,
usually that discipline or that mastery
is imposed from without, right?
You've got sergeants or lieutenants
or whatever that are teaching you or that,
and you're in a structure that is shaming you
and making you go forward, right?
From outside externally.
Whereas, and I think this is one of the reasons why
a lotta guys and gals who leave
the military have a hard time
is when you make the switch
to being an artist or an entrepreneur or a fitness athlete,
that now become self-discipline.
Right.
Nobody's giving you
the orders.
Self reinforcement,
self validation.
And that's a big, hard change to make.
That's a whole other dimension of reality.
Right.
You're not accountable to the lieutenant
or the general or whoever, but only to yourself.
The other thing, and I'm sure this is true
in endurance sports too,
is there's an element of drudgery in this, right?
And being able to embrace the drudgery,
to train, you gotta go out on the trail, da da da.
Yet another day I gotta get up, right?
Right.
Same thing in writing
or any creative enterprise.
There are times when it's just a slog,
but again, that's a kind of a warrior virtue too.
The warrior learns to, and the soldier learns
to just keep shovelin', keep diggin' the ditch.
It's no fun, there's no glamor,
but that's what it is.
Not the chain gang.
Yeah.
Yeah, but that's how anything is created, right?
Is it not?
Yes.
I mean, you have to show up day in and day out
and most days aren't so great.
And every once in a while you get that spark
and it's awesome and you live for that,
but really it is about falling in love with the process.
It's not about the accolades or the destination
or the the end point or the goal
or crossing any finish line.
It is truly just about the showing up.
Now, did you always feel that way, Rich,
or was that somethin' that you learned,
when you were doin' all of those Ironman's and stuff,
did you have that attitude
or was that something that evolved
through the course?
No, I mean,
I didn't get into it to like beat people or win races.
I really, I did have enough self-awareness
around it to know that I was getting into it
as a process of self discovery.
Ah, good for you.
I'm competitive with myself,
not with anyone else, but I learned,
I love the suffering and the mental
and physical challenge of the whole thing.
And I learned that as a young person, as a swimmer.
So, I had that kind of language for myself
before I got into ultra endurance and understood deeply
that it's about process and the slog,
like that's how I got to where I got as a swimmer.
That's how I, achieved academic,
like anything good that I've ever done has been about that.
So, that wasn't a lesson that needed to be taught to me.
I've always gotten that
and that's how I've approached the podcast
and everything else that I've done.
Like, I'm good at grinding.
Like if I have a talent, it's not athletic,
it's just I'm willing to suffer
and work harder than the next guy
and put in the grind when no one's looking.
And I think that's the secret sauce
and I've said this many times before,
but most people really wildly overestimate
what they can do in a year or so,
and overestimate what they can do in a year
and wildly underestimate what they can do in a decade
and as somebody who didn't publish their first book
until they were in their 50s and now has 20 books,
you're a living Testament to that sentiment.
Yeah, I'm what you
would term a grinder.
Yeah.
Like if that's a talent, if I have any talent, it's that.
But I am willing to get at the grindstone
and just keep hammering.
When I think of a younger version of you,
I think of Ryan Holiday, who actually introduced us,
thank you, Ryan,
Ah, yes.
for making the introduction,
but that's a guy who shows up for the page every day,
is very clear
Oh, he does, yeah.
that this is what he's here to do.
He's here to write books and he doesn't get caught
up in all the stuff that swirls around it.
Like, as soon as a book's done he's onto the next book
and the guy's crankin' out a book a year
and I see the same discipline
and approach to craft that you have.
Yeah, I'm amazed that Ryan does that
at such a young age.
It's unbelievable.
Really, how did he do that?
I don't know.
I don't know, the level of the, yeah.
And it's discipline.
He has a structure and a system
and he's transparent about it.
He's like I get these cards and I have these,
this is how I do it and then when it's done,
I put it in this box
and I think there's something magical and important
and you talk about this in "The War of Art"
about ritual and respect for ritual.
Like, those little things that seemingly don't mean anything
actually might be the most important things.
Definitely.
I'm definitely a believer in habits.
I say that an amateur has amateur habits,
and a pro has professional habits
and that's all the difference in the world.
Did you ever see that documentary,
"History of the Eagles," about the band, the Eagles?
No, uh uh.
Ah, well,
I'm gonna tell you a little story from that.
This is Glenn Frey was telling this story
that when he was like a young guy, just starting out,
he roomed with J.D. Souther who was another,
they were like together and they had an apartment right
above Jackson Browne's apartment.
And this is before
any of them had
Wow.
had any success at all.
And he could hear from his apartment above Jackson Browne's,
he would hear Jackson Browne going
through playing the piano,
and he would play like, he was working on a song
and he would play it one time, play it again, play it again.
But, and he would stop occasionally to make tea
and he had like a whistling tea, Jackson Browne would,
and this was a kind of a punctuation point
for Glenn Frey listening to this.
"Oh, there he goes to make another pot of tea,"
and then he would go back
and play that same thing again.
And it just 20 times, 30 times,
and what Glenn Frey said was,
"I learned, that's how you write a song."
It doesn't just come out of the air.
That Jackson Browne worked that over and over
until he had it exactly the way he wanted.
And that it was a grind.
It was, the daily, one step in front of another.
And I just thought that was a great story.
So, true.
Right.
He wasn't struck by lightning and this perfect song
maybe flowed from his mouth.
Yeah, maybe he was struck
by lightening when he first got the flash
of what that melody was,
but then it took forever to get
it down exactly the way he wanted it.
Right, so let's talk a little bit
more about that transition between amateur
or dilettante and "Turning Pro," right?
Which is the great follow-up to "The War of Art",
like this difference in, it's really a mindset shift, right?
Like, am I doing this as a side thing?
Or is this who I am?
And if so, what is my relationship
to the work I wanna create?
I mean, for me having defined resistance
as this negative force, then the next question becomes,
well, how do you get around it?
How do you overcome it?
And for me, it was the idea
of turning pro by which I mean that,
not that you only will work for money from now on
'cause usually if you're an artist or a writer
or whatever nobody's giving you any money anyway, right?
But it's the concept of thinking,
"If I'm an amateur and I run into adversity,
I'm gonna fold," right?
Because I'm not really in it.
I'm just doin' it for fun, right?
Or if I'm not in the mood, I'm not gonna work today.
Or if I've got problems with the family
or whatever, money, I'm gonna blow off today's work
or today's workout or whatever,
but a professional, if you think about Kobe Bryant,
you think about Tom Brady,
think about Michael Jordan,
I mean, a professional shows up every day,
does his work every day, plays hurt,
doesn't let anything stop 'em.
And not that a professional doesn't take a day
off every now and then, but a professional loves it so much
that they are willing to commit wholeheartedly
to it and to give themselves totally over
to whatever their aspiration is.
Yeah, and it's the relationship
to those obstacles that's different, right?
The obstacle is the way or the obstacle becomes the way
as opposed to the impediment
that's gonna get you to quit.
Yeah, right.
And that's the big difference.
And again, this is what you were talking about.
Process, it's a practice.
It's a today, tomorrow, the next day, the next day,
what we can do in a year, what we can do in 10 years.
It's not just getting to some particular imagined goal.
"Oh, I'm gonna win the Oscar and my life is gonna change."
It's a lifetime commitment
the things that we're talkin' about.
And I think what you did brilliantly
is also give the reverence to these creative pursuits
that they deserve in terms
of what's required to do them well, right?
We all understand that if you're Tom Brady
or you're Michael Jordan,
like you're showing up no matter what,
you're putting in crazy amounts of work,
like your level of dedication is insane.
But for some reason we don't think
about writing or standup comedy or even entrepreneur,
like all these other endeavors don't demand
that same level of respect.
We all think, "Well, I can," you saw it.
Your boss wrote a book.
You're like, "Oh, well, how hard can it be?
I could write a book."
Or you see a guy get up on stage and tell a joke,
you think it's easy.
And so we don't have the respect for the craft
that we would for what a great athlete does.
Yeah.
I mean, everybody thinks they can write.
Everybody thinks they can tell a joke,
but nobody thinks that they could be a brain surgeon
or they could be a concert pianist.
They get that, but they don't get the other thing.
But, and of course I was that way at the start, too.
Like I say, I thought, how hard could this be?
And it's hard (laughs).
Well, you have to live it out
so that you could write the book and tell
all of us so we could save a little bit of time, right?
How does the resistance show up for you now?
Well, you shared that one example,
but with your level of self-awareness,
you must be able to see it coming
a mile away compared to most people.
And yet still,
And yet, still no.
it still rises.
It's still so diabolical, resistance is so diabolical
and so nuanced that like I was saying before,
this one book that I'm workin' on,
I'm hearing that voice in my head,
this is when, "You writing is really dumb.
Nobody's gonna care," da da da da da da.
But I do have a rule that I have learned
and that I believe and that is that the stronger
the resistance that you feel,
the more important it is that you do that,
whatever it is you're resisting.
Yeah, talk a little bit about that more
'cause that's really powerful.
Another, a mantra that I say
is that resistance comes second.
Now, if we imagine that we were taking,
if this is our dream, our novel or our startup
or whatever it is, and we set it out in the sunshine
on a field or a flat thing like us,
immediately a shadow is gonna fall from this thing.
This is the dream and resistance is the shadow.
So, the shadow is exactly proportionate to the dream
so that if it's a big dream it's gonna be a big shadow.
So, in other words, the more, if you're feeling
and I say this to myself
'cause I'm talkin' about this thing,
the more resistance I feel to something,
the more certain I can be that there's a big dream there
and that I've gotta do it.
If it's a little dream,
you don't have any resistance at all.
So, in other words, when you're feeling
that horrible resistance it's a good sign.
Right.
It shows there's something there.
But it makes it all the harder, right?
The bigger the dream the more the fear around it, right?
Yeah, that's true but
that's life, right?
And the larger
the resistance, the more difficult it is to tackle.
And then the more toxicity you experience by ignoring it,
like everything gets ratcheted up.
But it's like
Yes.
the universe is knocking on your door saying,
"You gotta wake up and pay attention to this."
Yes, but again, what is the dream?
The dream is some sort of unfolding of who you are.
If it's a company that you wanna start,
if it's a nonprofit, it's a podcast,
if it's an ultra endurance thing,
that's your soul unfolding, yourself unfolding,
and revealing in a good way,
revealing like a flower blooming,
revealing what's there and that's
what we're here to do, I think.
So, whatever the pain is that's life to get to that.
Right.
Well, how do you communicate that to somebody who,
to go back to the example
of somebody who's not in a tremendous amount
of pain to tell that person you're here
to express who you uniquely are.
It's like, I'm banking a good paycheck.
I lease a nice car.
Like, what do you mean?
And I really don't like to answer that question
and it tends to bother me when people ask me that question
and there is no answer to it.
It's when they hit bottom,
when they're really ready then they'll do it
and they won't do it before that.
Right.
So, another reason to get
out of the way and allow them
their own process.
Yeah, exactly,
and I think it's one of the most thankless things
in the world to try to help someone in a state like that.
'Cause like, when they're ready,
or when I'm ready, when you're ready, we'll do it.
The mentor will present himself or herself.
Yeah, yeah.
So, walk me through a day in your life
in terms of how you structure things so that you're,
it's conducive to your art.
Well, let me take you back pre COVID
because it's a little different now.
I'm slacking off a little more that I should.
Oh, wow.
I would have thought it would have been the opposite.
No, no, but pre COVID,
and when we get back to this,
I'm like a gym person and I would get up really,
really early and go into Gold's in Venice and work out hard,
not as hard as you, but hard for me,
Probably harder these days.
and then I'd go to breakfast every morning
with a bunch of guys my age,
a bunch of geezers that I hang out with,
and then I'd go home.
It's now maybe 8:30, something like that.
Take care of whatever correspondence there is,
whatever emails as little as possible.
And then I'll sit down and really do the work,
whatever it is and turn everything off,
and lock the door, et cetera.
And I used to be able to work for four hours.
Now I can maybe work for three and then I'll,
when I'm done with that
I'll clean up whatever needs to be done.
And then I'm from the school
of the office is closed after that.
I turn off my brain, I don't dwell on it, I don't think.
I leave it up to the muse and just do whatever
we can in the evening, go to dinner or something like that
and start again the next day.
And very definitely keeping up
Do you still keep with the-
with it over a year at a time.
Do you still use the paper calendar?
Oh yeah, I do that.
You've done
your research, Rich.
You mark down your workouts
or how many hours you wrote that day, that kinda thing?
Which is important I think to record
what you did that day,
not in great detail or anything,
but just it's a little bit like journaling
only I just do it really simple.
I just say, I've worked on this,
I worked this many hours, enough.
Boom, I did it.
And somehow that nails it down.
I kinda say, and I do that with workouts too.
I'll kinda say, well, what did I do today?
I mean, you probably do that too, Rich, right?
When you're, you write it down 'cause it sinks in.
Yeah.
Also, if you're working towards a goal,
like, so the equivalent would be,
there's a race on the calendar
or this is when you have to turn the manuscript on, right?
And you kind of backpedal
from there and fill in the calendar going backwards
knowing what you need to do.
But like, there's something about the tactile experience
of writing it down as opposed to just knowing it
or having it in a digital calendar that not
only makes it more real, but also just,
it enhances your emotional attachment
and engagement to the whole process I think.
Yeah, I mean, I would, for me, it's self reinforcement.
I don't have any boss or a sergeant at the end
of the day that says to me, "Good job, Steve, you did that."
So, I gotta do that myself, right?
And it's the same way.
And for me, when I write it down that I did this workout
or I did this, that's kind of, if I can look at a calendar,
I got a month there and I can see check mark,
I can see like 30 check marks,
I go, that's pretty good.
When, if I have big gaps, I go,
"Oh man, I better, crank it up a little bit here."
But I think we need all the reinforcement we can get.
How much of that regimented mentality,
I mean, you were in the Marines, right?
Does it come from military experience?
Not really.
No, I think it just comes
from doin' the work in the real world.
Right.
And you just figured out your own way for it.
Yeah.
I mean, I've got in my closet,
I've got calendars going back
to like 19 wherever.
And you keep them all?
Yeah, I keep 'em, yeah.
(Rich laughs)
Well, let's talk about the new book.
"A Man at Arms" is coming out in March.
This is quite the adventure.
It's your return to the ancient world after a spell.
And this great character that shows
up in many of your books, Telamon,
who's this archetypical silent warrior figure
and I'm about 100 pages into it.
I'm really enjoying it.
And what's amazing to me reading this
is just the level of detail.
Like, I really feel like I am
in first century Judea and your command over
what that would feel like,
what it would smell like,
the experience of being in that place is unbelievable.
Like, the amount of research I can't imagine
that you would have had to put
into being able to fully grok
like what that world was like at that time.
Well, of course, a lot of it is fiction.
A lot of it, you're trying to just kind of create a world.
Like, if you were creating the world
of "Lord of the Rings" or "Game of Thrones," right?
You're creating a world,
but I spent a buncha time
in Israel researching another book.
And so, that kind of gave me, and in Jerusalem,
so that kind of gave me a feel
for it's actually like there, what it feels like.
And towards Sinai, the Sinai Desert
where this story takes place.
And but, actually right now
I'm reading "The Sun Also Rises," Hemingway's book from,
it's like the 10th time I've read it.
And he is an absolute master of detailed stuff like that.
And like, if he's talking about,
they're going fishing and he talks about how they walk
over this hill and there was a church
on the side and then the water went
over the styles and the dam like that
and we had the fish and we got the ferns,
we lay the ferns down and then layers
of fish on top of them and then we dug up the,
and as you're reading it, layer and layer a layer of detail,
you really get immersed in it.
And particularly when they're visual details,
so that you say, "Wow, I feel like I'm there,
I'm fishing with the guy.
I know exactly what it feels like."
Yeah.
So I definitely very much try to do that.
It's like a movie, right?
If Ridley Scott is blocking out a scene,
I mean, there's nothing in that scene
that's an accident, right?
Every prop, every ray of light,
everything is, the smoke, whatever it is,
is there to immerse you, the reader,
and create, or the viewer, and create the illusion
that you're actually there.
So when you were in Israel,
did you sort of drive south and track
this route a little bit to get a sense
of the landscape?
I didn't because
you couldn't cross into Egypt,
but I did as far as you could go in Israel, yeah.
But I actually, I wasn't thinking about this.
This book came like four years after the other one,
but everything is grist for the mill
and what I learned in Israel sort of,
it's all in the computer somewhere, yeah.
Right, and I loved the kind of structural setup
of the mute little girl and the warrior.
And you just, you know that this relationship
is gonna flower.
You wrote a blog post about this.
It's all about like, how do you get to I love you?
And you can see that coming.
And it feels to me, I mean, it's very cinematic.
It's sort of like, it's like "Gladiator" meets "The Road"
or something like that.
(Steve laughs)
As they traipse across
That's pretty good.
I like that.
this landscape on this crazy adventure
that has a lot to do with
the early years of Christianity
and the Roman Empire and it's beautifully rendered.
I mean, one of the,
you were talking about get to I love you.
Let me just talk about that just for a second
'cause it's sort of, I mean,
you're an entertainment background.
I'm sure you've heard this or thought about this,
but a lot of stories, a lot of movies,
are basically about get to I love you,
by which I mean the final moment that we're building to,
let me go back a minute,
you start with two characters that are as far apart
as you can possibly make them, right?
They hate each or for whatever reason they're opposite.
It's a cop, it's a criminal.
If it's a love story it's the guy and the gal,
whatever it is.
And the whole point of the story
is to get them to the point where they can,
if not literally say, I love you,
there's a gesture or something like that at the end.
And when we're watching this or reading it,
like you say, you could see it coming.
That's sort of what kinda pulls us through the story
'cause we know what's gonna happen at the end.
Yeah, you know it and yet, you can't look away.
It's like this tractor.
You want it, and again, our life is like that, right?
We meet somebody and we're trying to,
whether we want to or not come to some understanding,
come to some bond and that's kind of what keeps it going.
And I think that if you look at it at a deepest,
deepest level, if you wanna look at it at a level
of faith or spirituality, it's God.
It's getting to the belief in a loving divinity.
Or if you wanna stay at a lower level
of just human to human,
that's getting to the point where love
is greater than fear or greater than anger.
And if we wanna be in politics today,
we're in the United States as far away from that
as we could possibly be.
And I think we all want that in something,
but we don't know how to get there.
Hm.
Well, does it not begin-
I didn't mean
to take this into politics.
Yeah, well, it begins with a willingness
to try to grapple
with that dormant higher self within, right?
And one of the ways that you've kind of gotten
at that subject is by analogizing it to golf,
like this idea of the authentic swing.
Like no matter who you are,
like everybody has their own swing.
You can never master anybody else's swing.
If you try to change your swing, you can't do it.
Everybody has
their default swing, right?
Which is true.
And that's sort of a metaphor
for our unique blueprint that we all
come into the earth with
and are on this path to expressing that.
Yeah, our authentic self.
And in this story, "A Man at Arms,"
the book that you have in front of you there,
it's really the hero, Telamon,
who is like this one man killing machine
of the ancient world, like the Clint Eastwood,
"Man With No Name," you can tell at the start of the story
he's this ultra hardcore kind of solitary warrior
that he's looking for some, it's not, he isn't complete.
His philosophy is too dark.
It's too selfish.
It's too ego-driven.
And so, the point of kind of get to I love you
through that story is, I won't spoil anything for you or,
but that's kind of what the evolution
that you can feel is inside him.
He's trying to get to his authentic,
whatever it is and he's not there yet.
And I think all stories
Yeah, he's got
are about that.
all these layers,
protective layers around him.
He's a man without a country,
he's there for the dollar and he's a survivor, right?
He's able to make his way in the world
in accordance with his warrior code, but he's an outcast.
And so, there's something missing, right?
And this girl you know is going to complete that for him.
Which is really sort of a classic,
it's like a classic Raymond Chandler, "Private Eye"
is sort of that kind of-
It is a western
It is a western, yeah.
in a way.
It absolutely is a western.
Or a Clint Eastwood character in a Western
or a John Wick character in a contemporary thing is,
it's a similar sorta thing.
It's like in movies, we've seen this character,
we've seen that story
but it's always fresh and it's always new.
Well, you're a big proponent of stealing what works
and using those as templates
to create structure
Yes, I am.
for your work, with the Bhagavad Gita and "Bagger Vance."
Was there something that you relied
upon for "A Man at Arms?"
Definitely.
I mean, I definitely-
Not gonna say (laughs)?
Well, I'll say at least a little.
I certainly thought of it absolutely as a Western,
even though it's set in the first century A.D.,
and the reason that I wanted it to be kind of a journey
across the Sinai desert was I thought that's kind of
like "The Road Warrior," the post-apocalyptic,
or a Clint Eastwood or John Wayne movie
where there's always the wide open,
the cruel lawless wasteland, right?
Where a warrior-
You're gonna happen
upon marauders and all kinds of crazy obstacles.
Yeah, which is again, sort of like the hero's journey
that you or I go through, right?
Or it all even comes back to being a writer
or being an endurance athlete.
It's a kind of a wasteland
that the individual sort of enters
for his own reason and undergoes ordeals towards
some form of transformation at the end.
And that's, so I definitely thought of this absolutely
as a Western and even watched westerns
like you do when you're writing movies,
you're trying to, what can I steal from "The Wild Bunch?"
Or what can I steal from "The Searchers?"
So, yeah.
So, I definitely thought of it that way.
And why do you keep going back to, Telamon,
as this character?
He recurs in your work time and time again.
Like, what is it about this guy
that you just feel so connected to
that you have to keep writing about?
It's a great question and I don't know the answer to it
because in some way this is the character
of all the characters that I've written about
that I feel the closest kinship to in some way
and I also never planned this character.
When he appeared and he's been in like three other books
and he sort of appeared
on the page and he appeared fully formed.
Like he had a philosophy.
When he would start to talk,
and I wasn't even, I wasn't in charge of that,
he had a philosophy and I sort of thought to myself,
"I wonder what, I wish I could talk to him.
What does he think below that?
Why did he think that?
Why does he believe this?"
And so, I don't know.
There must be something in me that relates to,
it's a metaphor somehow.
I'm not sure what it is.
Telamon appears, not to go too deep into this,
but he appears, he can't seem to die.
He appears in one century
and he comes back in another century
and he hasn't aged and he's in a whole different place.
So, he's sort of like somebody that's stuck
in an archetype, like the universal soldier
that's condemned to come back
and fight war after war, after war.
And I mean,
in a way that's like-
Like Kung Fu.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
I hadn't even thought about that but that's,
or a lot of these western heroes are sort
of timeless archetypes, right?
A Clint Eastwood character or something like that.
It seems like they fought in war after war, after war
and they're gonna do it again.
So, somehow, again, I don't know the answer
to this question, Rich.
I don't know why he's fascinating to me
but just like you were talking
about doing another book of "Finding Ultra"
I know I'm gonna have to do another book
with Telamon,
With this guy, right?
and I'm dreading having to actually
get to that deep level.
Well, what I see in the character
is a guy whose experiences in the world
have maybe not embittered him but calcified him, right?
And out of self-preservation
has created these protective walls around him.
He's not gonna allow his emotions
to be impacted by anything external.
So, he's effective in surviving
and has these aspirational warrior abilities and yet,
he's broken and in pain, right?
And so, there's an opportunity to heal that somehow.
And that can take shape
in any number of journeys that this person goes on.
Yeah.
I mean, there's a moment where, as you know,
he takes on an apprentice, a young boy,
and they have a couple of mules
as they're crossing this desert.
And at some point, Telamon says something kind
to the young boy about the mules
and the boy says, "Shall we name them?
Should we give them names, these mules?"
And he says, "No."
He says, "I'm sorry I even know your name."
Right, but the kid was so excited
that Telamon was even talkin' to him
'cause this is the silent, strong, silent guy
who's clearly the mentor who's gonna teach
this young person his ways of the world,
but he's gonna do it sparingly
and only when he feels like
doing it, right?
Yeah.
Cool.
So, the book comes out late March, right?
Or-
March 2nd.
Oh, March 2nd, yeah.
That's exciting.
So, I'm sure you'll be doing some other podcasts
and talking about it.
It's very cinematic too.
Has there been any interest from
the movie business yet?
Not yet.
I don't know if anybody even knows it exists yet.
Do you still keep a toe in that world or no?
Not really.
No?
I let my subscription
to the "Hollywood Reporter" lapse.
You did?
Like five years went by and I never saw on my name in it.
Do you still have like a talent agent
in Hollywood or that's passed?
I don't.
I have a books to movies agent in New York, Jody Hotchkiss,
but I don't have...
You know how it is.
When your hair turns gray,
your career is over and Hollywood
as a screenwriter.
No, look at Ridley Scott.
The guy's like 80.
The guy's a director.
He's got two massive movies that he's shooting
like back to back coming up
I think.
Wow, is that right?
Yeah, it's crazy.
How old is Ridley now?
He's definitely,
81 or something?
yeah, he's definitely in his '80s.
God bless him.
It's insane, right?
Well, I do wanna, can we tell the story
about Frank Wuliger and "Bagger?"
'Cause it's so good and I think it-
How do you know Frank's name in this?
I told you I was in entertainment,
some roots back in that.
Because I think it's really,
it's inspiring and instructive
about what it means to honor that voice
within you and dial out the external voices
that are perhaps leading you astray.
(laughs) Well, Frank Wuliger was my agent
and he's a wonderful guy and we were friends.
And the way that we used to work is when I,
'cause I was basically a spec screenwriter,
I'd write something on spec
and if I'd had two or three ideas,
I'd go into Frank's office
and he would give me like two hours
and I'd pitch him the ideas.
And he would tell me, "No, you can't do that.
Fox is doing a movie like that now."
Or he'd kinda give me the marketplace take on things.
So anyway, I went into him one day,
the idea for "The Legend of Bagger Vance"
came to me just out of nowhere.
I was seized by it, my first book.
And I said to him, "Frank, I've got good news and bad news.
And the good news is I've got a new idea.
I'm really hot to do it.
And the bad news is, it's a book, it's not a movie."
And so Frank had been really working hard
on my behalf to kinda get me out there into the town
and people knew who I was.
So, he was completely pissed off at me,
'cause he said, "I've done all this work.
If you take a year off to write a book,
all that work is down the tubes."
And so I asked him, "Can you help me get an agent
in New York, a literary agent?"
And basically, he basically fired me.
He just flipped, he just wouldn't do it.
And so I just said, screw this, I'm writing it.
I don't care.
I'm just seized by it.
And so we sort of, we parted ways at that point.
And I went right and wrote the book.
Right, the idea of being like, A,
what do you mean you're gonna write a book?
Like I just put all this work into cultivating
your writing name
He's right, he's right.
in the screenwriting business
and it's gonna be about golf?
Like God.
Yeah, about golf.
It's like, that's not gonna work.
And you walk away from all of those opportunities
when you were getting some success
and on the precipice of really breaking through
in a big way to go off on this crazy tangent
to write this book and everybody told you, you were insane.
And I told myself that.
So, what was that,
like what was going on inside of you
that felt so compelled to make that decision?
I was just seized by this story, Rich.
I just, and when I look back on that,
today I would really block out
a story and figure out that that,
with that book I just kinda just let it go.
And even when I look at it now it's structured
in a really kinda crazy way.
But I think it works, at least the book works.
I don't think the movie worked, but I was just seized by it.
I had no choice.
I just had to do it.
In "The Authentic Swing,"
you talk about, it's sort of a behind the scenes look
at how the book came about
and ultimately the movie came about.
What is it about, can you speak to how golf works
for you as this analogy for these other ideas?
'Cause it does, like it's counterintuitive
and yet it completely makes sense when you explain it.
First of all, I know that people who are not into golf
it seems like the dopiest sport
in the world.
Yeah, I'm like,
I'm not into golf at all.
Like I have a hard time,
although I watched the Tiger documentary
and I was riveted by that.
Well, they say about golf and it's really true
that with almost any other sport,
if you don't play it and you see it like say,
motor racing or a surfing or mountain climbing,
even if you don't play it,
you can look at it and go, "Oh, that looks kinda cool.
Look at the Laird Hamilton going down that,"
but golf is an exception.
You look at golf, you go,
"It's a bunch of white guys wearing plaid pants.
It seems like they're fat guys, it's Donald Trump.
It's like the most, but trust me, it's a great sport.
And to prove it, Michael Jordan loves it.
John Elway loves it, Tom Brady.
So anyway, the one thing about golf,
you were talking about "The Authentic Swing"
before is I had two friends when I was a kid,
identical twins who played golf.
And the amazing thing to me was
they had completely different golf swings.
And I thought, shouldn't they have the exact same swing?
They're the same DNA.
And it is true that in some crazy way
we're born with a swing.
Before we ever pick up a club, you have a swing,
I have a swing, everybody around here has a swing.
And you cannot change that swing.
If you think about golfers like Fred Couples
or Jim Furyk that have these crazy loopy swings,
they didn't evolve that through study or,
so to me the idea of "The Authentic Swing"
and finding your authentic swing
is the equivalent of your authentic self.
It's what we were talking about before,
about being born with a gift and that's it.
And so, a lot of us like in golf,
people will try to mold themself
into some perfect kind of a swing and it never works.
And the real answer is if you can,
define your own authentic swing and then
fine tune it so that you don't have bad habits in there.
And so, I think that's the same thing in writing,
in art or anything in life is finding who we are.
We already are that thing,
and if we can just find it and be it
but that's the hardest thing in the world.
That's why they say know thyself
is like the hardest thing in the world to do.
Right, but that's what we're here to do,
right?
Yeah.
And to extend the golf metaphor,
there is this truth in that it's not about anyone other
than yourself and your relationship with yourself.
Yes.
It is the ultimate individual sport, right?
And this idea that you talk about of,
I forget how you phrase it exactly.
But most athletes are reacting
without a forethought in the moment,
whether they're hitting a backhand
or blocking a jump shot, but in golf,
there's stillness which forces you
to engage with your thinking mind which moves you away
from the ability to execute on what you're there to do.
And it's all about the process
of getting out of your own way, right?
And that goes back
Yes.
to the stripping away thing
in "Bagger" with the who are you question
to eradicate all the noise
so that you can be fully present.
Yes, and like, as you're saying,
golf is one of the few sports,
maybe shooting a free throw
or kicking a field goal is a parallel,
where you do it from a standing start.
Like you say, in basketball you're reacting
to somebody or tennis.
The ball's coming, you react to it.
And it's easier to do that in motion.
It's more, it's easier to do it
but from a standing start where your brain starts working,
but then there's a whole other aspect
of golf that was in this book, "The Authentic Swing."
And this is kind of a crazy thing and it gets spiritual
is that there's really no other sport
where you have a caddy.
We have another person standing
at your shoulder that technically is your servant, right?
You're paying 'em to carry the bag.
But as we all know, the bond between the caddy
and a golfer's a...
And in the Bhagavad Gita where you have
the great warrior, Arjuna, his charioteer is Krishna.
I.e. God in human.
And that was the parallel that I drew.
Like, so, God appears as a servant
at your side and a kind of advisor.
And I think that a lot of Christians
who believe in a personal savior related
to the character of Bagger Vance that way.
But I also do think if you think about,
I know we're getting into deep waters here but-
No, this is the stuff I love the most.
If you think about "The Odyssey" and Odysseus,
he's on his journey, people forget about this,
he's accompanied by the goddess, Athena.
And he talks to her all the time
and she intercedes for him and anybody that,
Martin Luther King or somebody would talk
to Jesus all the time, like it was at his shoulder,
and so the same thing with Arjuna
the great warrior and Krishna is at his side
as an instructor and as a divine archetype.
And I do think, this is when I say I believe in the muse,
and although resistance is the negative side of it,
the goddess is the positive side of it that,
when I said I was seized
by the story of Bagger Vance and had to write it,
that's what that was, it was coming from another,
so that was the equivalent of Krishna
at your shoulder or Athena or Jesus or whatever.
Some entity from another dimension of reality,
from a dimension of potentiality, where do songs come from,
where the ideas come from, where do books come from?
I think there's a lot of reality.
So back to golf, the idea in golf that you have this person
at your shoulder that guides you and you can see
if you watch a golf tournament,
you watch Phil Mickelson or Tiger or whatever,
they turn to the caddy all the time, the caddy saves them.
In other sports you don't, have Michael Jordan can't stop
and confer with, or anything like that, right?
So, I do think that there's a real spiritual aspect to that
or at least a metaphor for something spiritual.
Right, right, right.
Yeah, and that's one of the reasons why
the Tiger documentary was so interesting hearing
the perspective of his caddy.
Have you seen the documentary yet?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then when Tiger fires him and the guy's like,
I mean, it's such a sacred relationship
and that seemed to be a real turning point
in terms of how Tiger was approaching the world
at that point in his life.
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah.
And like Dustin Johnson,
I don't know if he leaves like number one
or whatever he is now, his brother's is his caddy.
And they've been like, and he's a real good player, too.
His brother, Austin.
And somehow that's in a way,
a secret to his success that you can see
these two brothers are really in it together.
It's not a one man fight, it's a two-minute fight.
Right.
So, what happened with the movie "Bagger Vance?"
It kinda went sideways didn't it?
Yeah, it went sideways.
I don't know.
I mean, it's such an amazing cast.
Redford directing.
You got Matt Damon, Will Smith, Charlize Theron.
Yeah, I don't know.
Sometimes these things
just don't work, right?
I should ask you.
One thing I'll say is I think golf
is an impossible story to film.
There's only been one good golf movie
and that was "Caddy Shack."
Just a total force.
It's a hard thing to do.
I don't wanna say anything negative about anybody.
Right.
Did "Gold in the Kingdom" ever get made into a film?
I think it did, but it was a very small movie that,
I actually have the disc.
I've never been able
Oh, it did.
to put it in the machine.
When I was a lawyer I was involved in,
I can't remember who I was representing.
I think a producer who was trying to acquire the rights
or something like that, but I never knew that it got made.
Yeah.
I mean, that's an another impossible movie
to make 'cause it's so internal.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, how do you manifest
Great book.
that cinematically?
Right.
All right.
Well, we gotta wind this down,
but I wanna end on, or maybe two things
I wanna talk about.
We can't stay here
all day, Rich?
We can.
I'm happy to talk to you,
but I wanna be conscious of your time.
Where does talent fall into all of this?
That's a great question.
I'm really not a believer in talent.
I mean, I think that now,
I've said this before, people tell me, "Oh, I'm a talent,"
but for 30 years they told me I was a bum,
and I was a bum because I hadn't learned,
I didn't know what I was doing.
I think obviously you have
to have some sort of a gift, right?
If you're gonna be a runner
you have to have certain amount of speed, right?
But I certainly think in,
like you and I are grinders, right?
Yeah.
And I'm definitely,
I believe that work is for me, 80% of it,
maybe more, 85% of it.
On the other hand, Bob Dylan, Neil Young, Joni Mitchell,
they had talent,
but the ying-
There are people
that have talent.
God bless 'em.
There are people that do have incredible talent.
But there's also a lot of,
I mean, you've been in this town a long time.
There's a lot of incredibly talented people here
who aren't fully expressed or recognized
for what they do for other reasons.
Yeah.
So, it isn't always a function
of that and there's-
Or their talent works
against them.
Right, right, right, right.
We certainly see it in athletics, right?
You have a lot of players that come out
or they're drafted in the first round
for whatever it is and they fizzle.
And then Tom Brady was drafted whatever he was.
I forget what he was but way, way, way at the back.
Turns out to be the greatest player of all time.
So talent can be a negative if you can,
if you're relying on it too much.
If you're a basketball player,
a football player and you got speed, you got size,
maybe you don't have to do the work.
Sure, but I think we over index for talent
and we under appreciate the grinders.
Yeah (laughs).
And I think,
in so many pursuits, whether it's writing or anything else,
often the prize goes to the guy
who just refuses to walk off the field
and just keeps showing up and keep showing up.
Look how long it took you to get your first book published.
I see that time and time again, and it's not sexy.
Like that's not the growth hack
that everybody's looking for.
No, yeah.
It's the hardest way to do it.
But you learn along the way
so that when your persistence meets
with some sliver of opportunity
you're more prepared than you would have been ordinarily.
Yeah, but again, and there's no substitute
for that flash from above when it comes in,
but then that's when the grinding pays off
because you're ready, you've built the tools for it.
And when the inspiration comes,
you're capable of handling it.
Yeah.
Well, it's a good news, bad news thing is it not?
Like, bad news, maybe you're not that talented.
Good news, you can learn to grind.
Like, this is a skillset that you can develop
that's accessible to you.
Yeah.
Right.
Absolutely.
And if you can master that,
then you're putting yourself way ahead of 99% of people
out there who just aren't willing to put in the work.
So, it's really a function of like,
how badly do you want it?
Exactly.
And that goes back to the pain thing, right?
Are you in enough pain?
Yeah.
I hope you are
Yeah (laughs).
'cause it's gonna be a long road.
Yeah.
So, what is the, if somebody's watching
or listening to this,
you probably hate this question,
but if they're sitting there thinking,
"I got this thing I wanna write
or I have this idea that I wanna execute on and I've just,
I've been unable to get out of my own way
but it's like right there for the taking,
like how do you get people off the dime?"
Again, I say it's what I said.
It's the most thankless
I tried to get
thing in the world.
back to you on that.
Because if somebody's not ready to do it,
like I wasn't ready forever and forever and forever,
nobody, anything someone said to me would have just,
I would roll right off me.
But when I was ready and you don't have any clue
when that's gonna be, I think, then it happened.
So, one thing I would say to people,
and it's usually younger people is that,
this is what a friend of mine once said to me,
people always tell you that life is short,
but actually life is long.
And if you're 24 years old or 34 years old,
I mean, when I was 34 years old, I was still 21 years away
from having a book published,
even though I've been busting my ass for all that.
So, if I would say to a younger person,
take some pressure off yourself.
You don't have to, it's all this bullshit
in the social media that there's
a hack and you can do it tomorrow.
Enjoy the trip.
Pay attention, keep your eyes open on the journey.
When it's ready to happen, it'll happen.
That's really powerful advice I think.
I think it also is about rebutting
all these cultural and social influences on people.
Outside of the hacks it's just like,
here's the path that's laid out in front of you
and if you wanna be successful,
you go to this school or you get
this job and you work hard and success looks like X, right?
Where in truth, only you know in your heart of hearts
underneath all of these layers
what that's gonna look like for you
and that might take time, but there is something to be said
and a lack of appreciation for doing a walkabout,
like, which is essentially what you did
which was your own sort of Telamon soul journey
of self discovery in order
Yeah, yes.
to return and come back
to engage with your personal truth.
But it took time and it took you trying lots
of different things and giving
yourself permission to do that.
And I think that's something
that more people perhaps did in earlier ages,
which is really frowned upon now.
Yeah, it is.
And in truth, when you look at life and say,
it is long, why are you in such a hurry?
Like, there's this idea that if you're,
if you have to take one year of school over
are you gonna take a gap year that suddenly
you've missed out and the world
is gonna pass you by is fucking bullshit
and it's not in people's best interests or in service
to really trying to self-actualize by telling people that.
Yeah, there's so much pressure on everybody today to...
I'm glad I'm not, I don't wanna say I don't wanna be young
but it's a tough, if you're a young person today,
the pressure that's put on you
and just what's out there in the site Geist it's really,
it's artificial, it's false.
It doesn't coincide with our inner reality,
with our soul reality.
And we have to somehow disabuse ourselves,
free ourselves, break out of the spell
that's been cast on us.
Yeah, it's very limiting
and it's fear-based too, right?
It's betting on you being too afraid to do any,
like the cost of breaking outside
of like this norm is too high.
Yeah.
And most people
aren't willing to pay that
because of the social consequences.
And of course, about myself,
it wasn't like I decided to do that.
It just, I screwed up and it happened to me.
Yeah.
So.
And I think people are,
there's this expectation that when you're 18
you're supposed to know what it is that you wanna do.
It's just like preposterous,
right?
Yeah, yeah.
And if you haven't figured that out yet
like what's the matter with you?
It takes a little bit longer
doesn't it?
Yeah, 18, 28, 38,
keep goin', yeah.
All right.
Well, cool.
How do you feel?
Great.
I think we did our job.
I gotta say, thanks to you, Rich,
for bein' so prepared and makin' me think here
and I was really looking forward to meeting you
and to having this experience and it's been
everything that I hoped it would be
and I hope that we can keep somethin' goin' here,
and if I haven't totally exhaust,
if we haven't wrung
out the lemon,
No, no, no.
squeezed the lemon.
I'm just still trying to calm my nerves
over just having the opportunity to meet you.
Like, you being here today is incredibly meaningful to me
and I mean that with all of my heart.
Likewise, likewise.
It's really-
It's been great.
It's really special for me and I appreciate you,
and I hope that we can become friends
and I'd love to have you back on whenever
you wanna come back on and talk.
Consider it done,
I'm here for you,
I mean anytime.
my friend.
If there's any juice left in the lemon we-
There's plenty,
oh come on.
We can squeeze it.
Look at you.
I could try to extract lemon juice from you
for the rest of my life
and we'd never get to the bottom of it.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
A real pleasure.
It was great.
Steve's new book is called "A Man at Arms,"
available March 2nd out everywhere
you find books?
Yeah,
pretty much everywhere.
Check it out.
It's really a great read.
Thank you for putting
Thank you.
that book out there.
And if you're interested in all
of the things that we're talking about today,
pick up "The War of Art," "Turning Pro,"
"Nobody Wants to Read Your Sh*t."
You got all, "Do the Work."
You got all these great books,
regardless of how it feels to shoulder
this moniker you are a guru of creative expression
and you've helped millions of people, myself included.
And I can't thank you enough,
so come on back and talk
to me again.
All right.
That's great, Rich.
Thanks very much.
It's a real pleasure to meet you and to be here
and I hope we can do it again.
Absolutely.
Also, if you wanna connect with Steve,
stevenpressfield.com?
And on all the,
Yeah.
you're on Twitter and all those places, right?
Yeah, cool.
I think on Instagram
it's Steven_Pressfield
but I'm sure you can find it.
Okay.
There's only one.
And then on Twitter,
Steven Pressfield?
I don't even know.
You don't know (laughs).
Cool.
Thank you.
All right, thank you.
Peace.
Lights.